Kimmel Fallon Colbert all of them go
after the NRA Americans are not buying
what the media is selling and we're
about to hit the deck at deadline so
what does that mean for all the illegal
immigrant dreamers and Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
oh we have so many things to get to
today I'm speaking tonight in Omaha we
are sold out 1500 seat theater I'm doing
a full on exposition on the Second
Amendment what its meaning is where it
comes from and what it protects tonight
so look for that online or if you're
there in person I look forward to seeing
you there we've a lot to get to on the
show as well we're going to talk about
the security clearance status for Jared
Kushner we're gonna talk about the
confirmation bias that is now overrun
the media we're going to talk about
Dick's Sporting Goods supposedly banning
their sale of quote/unquote assault
weapons which they actually did five
years ago and now they're just reopen
but before we get to any of that I first
want to talk a little bit about more
facts that are now coming out about the
shooting so every day there are more
facts that are coming out about the
shooting now we sort of know what we
know at this point until a full
investigation is undergone but here's a
fact that should matter to you when it
comes to how Americans feel about what
happened in parkland and who they blame
about what happened in parkland it is
not the NRA it is not while biding gun
owners so Rasmussen had a poll yesterday
a new survey and it suggests this is
after the CNN propaganda Town Hall the
the two minutes hate on CNN here's what
Rasmussen Reports quote 54 percent of
American adults believe the failure of
government agencies to respond to
numerous warning signs from the
prospective killer is more to blame for
the mass shooting only 33 percent
attribute the deaths more to a lack of
adequate gun control 11 percent opted
for something else among Americans who
have elementary children at elementary
school children or secondary school aged
children
61% think the government is more to
blame just 23 percent of those adults
felt a lack of adequate gun control 41
percent of respondents by the way say
that they opted for stricter gun control
40 percent say more action is needed to
treat mental health issues only 50
percent of Democrats actually said that
a lack of gun control was the real
problem here
all of it just to say whenever you see
polls are some polls out today
suggesting that even among Republicans
support for gun control is rising you
need to take all of that with a grain of
salt because that's like asking
Americans as I've said in the past it's
like asking Americans are you for Less
government spending the answer is always
yes but then you say okay what do you
want to see cut and suddenly Americans
run for the hills well the same thing is
true with regard to gun control people
say are you for more gun control most
people go yeah sounds good why not keeps
bad
at the hands of bad people and then when
you say okay well that's gonna mean
we're after gonna ban all the rifles
then all the Americans say well no we're
not gonna do that then the poll suddenly
shift so specifics are very different
from general propositions that are put
forward in these polling numbers all of
which goes to show you that the media's
attempt to paint this as the the
shifting points on gun control it's just
not true it's just not correct and the
fact is that even Democrats are split on
this they don't want to talk about it
but they are then that news is obvious
since The Huffington Post reported
yesterday morning after the Las Vegas
Massacre the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee is regional press
secretary Evan Lucas key actually wrote
to candidates in the Northeast not to
politicize the shooting he wrote quote
teams last night's shooting will
dominate the news today and will garner
serious coverage the rest of the week
you and your candidate will be
understandably outraged and upset as
will your community however do not
politicize it today
now the Caspi was right politicizing
shootings in the aftermath shootings bad
form and it's gotten even worse over the
past week and a half and all the media
reported this is just a grassroots
movement that was happening on gun
control and now it turns out that the
so-called marked for our lives that's
happening in Washington DC on March 24th
at which some of the student witnesses
and student survivors at Parkland are
going to be the featured speakers that
this is now being backed by Planned
Parenthood it's being backed by black
lives matter it's being backed by
moveon.org it's being backed by every
town for gun safety so all of these
organized
leftist movements are now getting behind
these kids and astroturfing what is
going to be very large March in
Washington DC that results in virtually
nothing and the reason that's gonna
result in virtually nothing is again
because the American people do not
support this the American people look at
what happened in parkland and what they
see is a failure of law enforcement
which is why yesterday when North Texas
sheriff put out a notice that got him
wide acclaim he the Denton County
Sheriff Tracy Murphy told his deputies
quote with the recent tragedy in Florida
I wanted to make my clear my policy on
responding to an active shooter all
commissioned deputies if you respond to
an active shooter you are expected to
take immediate action we do not stage
and wait for SWAT
we do not cover in a parking lot we do
not wait for another agency we go in and
do our duty we go in to engage and stop
the shooter and save lives if for any
reason you feel you cannot follow this
directive please inform your supervisor
and we will work to get you reassigned
okay this is the
most Americans feel about what the
authorities ought to be doing even
though the left wants to suggest that
this was not a failure of authority
whoever would prefer to jump into the
debate on this on this moralistic level
the left would prefer to suggest that
there's a moral failure failure that's
taking part on the place of those who do
not support widespread gun control and
that of course is not true Marco Rubio
is one of the people who's been hit
hardest from that senator Rubio from
Florida you remember he was at that Town
Hall two minutes hate on CNN and he was
shellacked by a bunch of the students
one of the students even comparing him
to the mass shooter himself Rubio put
out a tweet today
that I think sums up the state of our
gun control debate he said quote the
debate after Parkland reminds us we the
people don't really like each other very
much we smear those who refused to agree
with us we claim a judeo-christian
heritage but celebrate arrogance and
boasting and worst of all we have been
infected the next generation with the
same disease
now he's getting ratioed are there a
bunch of people on the Left who didn't
like that he said this their brunch
people who thought was just terrible
that he would say something like this
but he is 100% correct the fact is that
the left has turned this into a
referendum on the moral character of
people who disagree with them and most
Americans are not up for that most
Americans are not interested in
castigating their fellow Americans as
murderers and murderers supporters which
is why it's really fascinating there
been a bunch of corporations that have
disassociated from the NRA over the last
week there is a poll out today from
morning consult that showed every single
corporation every single corporation
that disassociated from the NRA in the
aftermath of this gun control debate has
been losing losing public support
because they'll gain four or five points
in public support from Democrats but
lose 60% of public support from
Republicans who feel like they're under
attack and the reason Republicans feel
like they're under attack is because
they are under attack okay the left they
say they're not for removing second
Amendment rights they only want rational
reasonable gun controls that's just not
true they want to remove semi-automatic
weapons from every person in the United
States if they could have their way that
is the end goal they won't be honest
about it many members of the left but
this is actually what they want and you
can see it in the arguments that they're
making so today the New York Times has a
full piece about how the ar-15 is
essentially military technology in the
hands of civilians well that's true of
any semi-automatic rifle they say well
look at the ar-15 look at its muzzle
velocity it has 3,000 feet per second
muzzle velocity this is true of any
two to three or 5.56 millimeter ammo
firing rifle the muzzle velocity on
those rifles is very high it always has
been it will continue to be the notion
that it's just military technology in
the hands of civilians again every rifle
then his military technology in the
hands of civilians because every rifle
was at some point military technology in
the hands of civilians even bolt-action
rifles were military technology in the
hands of civilians this argument is akin
to saying that the engine in your car is
just like the engines in the cars of
people in the military okay that's true
but it doesn't take you very far and
when people on the left rip on the ar-15
and suggest the ar-15 is the root of all
evil this just demonstrates complete
lack of gun knowledge there are a
thousand types of the ar-15 there are
many many different types of
semi-automatic rifle that fire at
similar velocity with the similar
callable with similar similar caliber
ammunition banning the ar-15 or the
branded ar-15 would do nothing to stop
the spread of rifles and it would do
nothing to stop the the actual problem
of school shootings by the way there's a
study out today showing that school
students have actually been declining in
recent years not increasing declining
we're not allowed to talk about these
statistics of course because to do so is
seen as somehow undermining the case in
favor of pushing against school
shootings but the reality is that just
as gun violence in the United States has
declined markedly from its highs in
1992-1993
school shootings have been declining in
recent years pretty rapidly that doesn't
mean that what happened in parkland
isn't tragic and horrible and an active
evil it does mean that we ought to take
a look at the measures that we are
purporting to push and compare those to
the rights that we are attempting to
infringe and what rights are we in
tempting to infringe well the answer is
all semi-automatic rifles so I remember
made this case on MSNBC he's given a lot
of credit for the left from this because
I remember is a lawyer but he does
really bad legal analysis here and I
will explain why he explains the Second
Amendment and his view does not protect
a ar-15s his logic here makes no sense
the Second Amendment does not apply to
ar-15
it does not apply to assault-style
weapons it never has Congress may
legally ban those weapons without
touching the Second Amendment that's a
legal fact but it's hard for me then
that is not a legal fact that is not a
legal fact
okay what he says there if you go back
to the screen where he puts up some text
on the screen the screen that he says
there well what he says that the Supreme
Court has never ruled that ar-fifteens
are protected by the Second Amendment
well that does not mean that there is no
right to an ar-15 the Supreme Court has
never actually ruled on whether twitter
is protected by the First Amendment
because that's never come up before of
the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
rejects certiorari on cases all the time
doesn't mean that the right doesn't
exist
case is legally illiterate I'll explain
why it's even more legally illiterate in
just a second first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at policy
genius so if you've got a car you have
car insurance it's got a home you have
home insurance and you got a life
you should have life insurance okay if
you're a responsible human being you
should be protecting your life with life
insurance you should be ensuring that
your family is safe you should be
ensuring that your family is secure if
god forbid something terrible should
happen to you but four out of ten people
do not have life insurance there's no
excuse for that policy genius has made
it easier to understand compare and buy
life insurance so here's the way that it
works you go to policy genius calm and
in five minutes you can compare quotes
from over 15 life insurance providers
when you compare quotes this is
competitive shopping you will save money
it is that simple they've helped over 4
million people shop for insurance
they've placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage they don't by the way just
do life insurance they also do health
insurance disability insurance pet
insurance renter's insurance all these
insurance programs you can shop around
for just by using policy genius so if
you've been putting off getting life
insurance because it's depressing to
talk about what happens if you die don't
be stupid because once you're dead it's
too late so make sure that you go to
policy genius com get your quotes apply
in minutes it is that easy you'll be
glad you did it and more importantly
your family will be glad you did if
something terrible should happen to you
god forbid again protect yourself
protect your family there's no excuse in
my view for being irresponsible and not
having a life insurance policy go to
policy genius.com
check it out policy genius.com again the
best way to shop for life insurance
okay so Melbourne makes the case it
makes this argument that because the
Supreme Court has rejected certiorari
certiorari is an appeal so the way it
works is that you have a case it goes to
a district court judge that is then
appealed up to a circuit court judge who
goes to the circuit court of appeals and
then finally it's appealed all the way
up to the Supreme Court
what is sense at the Supreme Court is
something called a writ of certiorari
which is essentially a petition asking
that the Supreme Court take up the case
now Supreme Court will reject writs of
certiorari for a variety of reasons some
of those reasons
include the fact they agree with the the
Court of Appeals sometimes they say the
case isn't right because it's very
common claim that a case has not
actually reap right has not reached
ripeness because there are a bunch of
other circuit courts they have not ruled
on the case there are cases where they
say that it's not just an issue of law
they want to take up there are million
reasons to reject it to reject writs and
certiorari and it is also true that none
of the cases that have been brought
before the Supreme Court specifically
deal with ar-15s because there's not a
state in the country that has attempted
to actually ban ar15 even in California
there's only recently in attempt to
quasi ban ar-15s but even that ban is
not supremely clear and certainly
confiscation of ar-15s has never been
tried and if it were to go up to the
Supreme Court there's a very good shot
that it would be shot down but Mel Birsa
jests and this is actually a really
dangerous constitutional point that
Melbourne is making because it
essentially says that if the Supreme
Court has not ruled on an issue you
don't have a right to it so if the
Supreme Court hasn't ruled on whether
twitter is protected free speech then
that means that you don't have a right
to it now you see the Melbourne would
never agree to the same logic with
regard to say same-sex marriage before
oberst all right so before a burst fell
the Supreme Court rejected same-sex
marriage cases over and over and over
rejected a bunch of writs of certiorari
and what re Melbourne have said there is
no right to same-sex marriage oh that's
I know of course he wouldn't have said
that he would have said in my view
there's a right to same-sex marriage
it's inherent in the text of the
Constitution and just because the
Supreme Court has not accepted the case
yet doesn't mean the right doesn't exist
in fact the reality is that under the
9th and 10th amendments the Constitution
explicitly states that rights that are
not overtly stated in the Constitution
of the United States itself are still
rights that are held by the people in
other words the Bill of Rights is not
meant to be a comprehensive Charter of
Rights it's meant to point out some of
the most specific rights that it wants
protected from the federal government
but that does not mean that there are
other rights that don't exist all other
rights don't exist beyond which the
second amendment is pretty clear about
what it means when it says a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the preservation of a free State the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed it's specifically talking
about civilians having access to guns
that they can then use when they go into
the militia at the time these were
military light weapons right I mean
these were rifles these were muskets and
that same principle carries forward so
what Melbourne is saying here makes no
sense on a legal level but here's the
more important point when I remember
once again an ar-15 when the New York
Times points out the ar-15 that means
they want to ban every semi-automatic
rifle in the United States because
there's no serious distinction between a
Bushmaster two to three and an ar-15
there is no significant distinction
between between you know very
Springfield rifle and an ar-15 you know
there are a thousand types of rifle all
of which fired the same sort of caliber
ammunition and just because some look
scarier than others doesn't mean that
they are less scary than others which is
why when you take a course in guns the
very first thing they say is that of
course you don't fire it anywhere near a
person of course you don't fire it it's
something you're not willing to destroy
rifles are meant to do damage rifles are
meant to kill things rifles are meant to
destroy things they're meant to kill
people presumably people who are bad who
come into your home but a rifle as a
tool of killing that does not mean that
a rifle itself is so inherently
dangerous that we have to be on all of
them
this one's one correlation the left
attempts to draw between the number of
guns in a particular society and the
level of murder in particular society
just does not hold that's particularly
true for rifles the more people are
killed by hands in fists every year in
the United States that are killed by
rifles in the United States and gun
ownership alone by civilian population
generally is not a good proxy for crime
rate gun ownership rates in places like
Vermont are extraordinarily high come on
has an extraordinarily low crime rate
the same thing is true in New Hampshire
and if you go to other states some some
places Louisiana there's very high gun
ownership rate there's very high crime
rate now important to note most of that
crime is not taking place in the boonies
most of that crime is taking place in
the major cities most of which have
actual gun control regulations on the
books and most of which are governed by
Democrats all of which is to say that
the the simplistic attempts to draw a
point of concurrence between a cross
point of data between gun ownership and
and murder that doesn't really hold it
doesn't really hold doesn't even hold in
Europe by the way where Norway has many
more guns per civilian than Britain does
and Britain has a has twice as bad a
murder rate so these these things just
the statistics just do not hold for any
of this now in a second I'm going to
show you how it is that there are so
many folks on the Left who ignore all of
this in favor of the virtually signaling
and that begins of course with our late
night house now one of the great you
since I think one of the things that's
helping to destroy comedy in the country
is the feeling that there are certain
areas of American life that used to be
off-limits for politics where we didn't
feel like we were gonna be assaulted
based on our politics when we turned on
our TV and we watched Johnny Carson
Johnny Carson was studiously anti
political meaning that he was a Democrat
apparently he was not a Reagan fan
although he got to know Reagan and ended
up liking him Johnny Carson was a
Democrat but you wouldn't know that from
watching Johnny Carson Jay Leno was a
sort of halfway Republican you wouldn't
know that from watching him because Jay
Leno was studiously non-political now
all of our late-night host have
basically become political hacks and you
can see that at work so last night
Colbert Kimmel Fallon all of them are
ardent leftist and all of them have
decided when they need to go balls to
the wall in pushing for gun control so
here here's a mash-up of Colbert and
Kimmel and Fallon here hear them talking
about Trump's gun proposals with the
Olympics over 90 countries have departed
South Korea yep 90 groups waving goodbye
or as the NRA calls those sponsors
although gun owners if you go into
almost any business and show them your
gun you get stuff for free it's really
here in reality there was an armed
sheriff's deputy on site and it made no
difference but Trump even has an
explanation for that the reason a
teacher with a handgun
would be able to neutralize a shooter
with an automatic weapon is because the
teachers love the kids more see this is
what happens when we elect a president
who thought paul blart mall cop was a
documentary it would be ridiculous
coming from anyone but especially from
Trump he's gonna run in yo when Trump
ran for president that was the first
time he ran in his entire life okay so
all the late night hosts universally
talking about how stupid it is to talk
about why good people with guns can stop
bad people with guns of course this is
idiocy Kimmel's point particularly is
incredibly stupid first of all he says
that the shooter had an automatic weapon
the shooter did not have an automatic
weapon people on the Left who are
talking about this stuff should at least
learn basic terminology so they don't
sound so they don't sound like complete
morons but they're not bothering to do
that and it's evident and all of this is
really quite terrible for the level of
political discourse in the country
because when you have laughing audiences
scoffing at the idea that an armed
teacher can save anyone then anyway
and you suggest that maybe we ought to
arm more security guards in schools and
Jimmy Kimmel just laugh that off by
suggesting that an armed security guards
did nothing at this school even though
there are many schools all over the
country our armed security guards
everyday are stopping people with
weapons like legitimately there there's
armed security guards at I think it's
over fifty percent of schools have some
form of armed security and those armed
security guards metal detectors there
are a lot of weapons that are stopped
every year going through those those
metal detectors
apparently Jimmy Kimmel opposes those as
well simply because he thinks that a
generalized regime of gun control is
better and then he and Colbert and
Fallon all of them suggest that if you
oppose their agenda which they've not
made clear they haven't exactly said
what they want other than mass banning
of guns which is never going to happen
there are 300 million weapons in the
country and a hundred million rifles
when you say it when they suggest that
if you oppose them this means that you
are a bad person and what's amazing is
that they've felt and they'll blowback
in the ratings now part of this I think
is the universality of leftist feeling
in late-night means that you have no
alternative nobody gonna switch from
Kimmel to Fallon so you can hear the
same gun control messaging but part of
it is also that the ratings are so far
down on all of these shows overall that
the audience is fragmented okay Jimmy
Kimmel's ratings are not anything like
what Johnny Carson's ratings used to be
because there are lots of networks very
few people are actually watching these
late-night shows in comparison to the
number of people who are watching
late-night shows before so they're
really not broadcast their narrow cast
even though they're on the networks and
so Jimmy Kimmel can say in full honesty
that there's no way to to go too far in
bashing and president Trump for the GOP
not at all I don't think you can go too
far I think that you know I'm still
doing a comedy show and I need to be
funny and entertain my audience but I
also think that we've matured enough to
the point where we can accept late-night
talk-show host speaking about a serious
subject and I think that it's almost
necessary now okay it's almost necessary
now for late-night host to talk about
political subjects well actually what
Jimmy Kimmel has shown is it's necessary
for our late-night host to study the
subjects before they talk about them
because literally every day he says
something that's stupid about politics
including in that clip a very short clip
him talking about automatic weapons
being used in the shooting which of
course they were not and it's not just
Jimmy Kimmel unfortunately the entire
media have shown themselves virtually
the entire media
themselves to be activists on gun
control issues rather than objective
journalists okay so today's examples
come courtesy of CNN
so CNN has been the worst on this it's
so funny they're all these folks in the
media who are constantly complaining
that people like President Trump are
ripping on the media that people like me
are ripping on the media how dare we rip
on the media you know that or that Trump
more importantly Trump rips on the media
and therefore Americans don't like the
media no as I said in my speech at CPAC
we didn't like you before we had serious
problems with the media before because
we feel like you're lying to us when you
claim that you're objective when you are
clearly not objective when you are
clearly not objective okay now as an
example of CNN not being objective today
Dick's Sporting Goods announced that
they were going to immediately halt
sales of assault-style rifles and
high-capacity magazines and all of their
stores including their field and stream
stores I guess they have these things
and banned the sales of all guns to
anyone under 21 now after Sandy Hook
they'd already stopped the sale of
assault-style weapons which is a
meaningless term meaning essentially
rifles that look scary
they've done that after Sandy Hook
they're reiterating that today and
extending it to a few more of their
stores the chairman and CEO said on Good
Morning America when we saw what the
kids were going through and the grief of
the parents and the kids who were killed
in parkland we felt we needed to do
something in other words there's an
emotional appeal they responded to the
emotional appeal now who cares I mean
the reality is who cares because most
people who are buying some is exporting
goods we're not actually buying
assault-style rifles from Dick's
Sporting Goods they haven't been able to
for years now if they want to raise
their age of buying 221 that's fine it
just means the person who's 19 and wants
to buy a handgun is simply gonna walk
across the street to the local gun store
and buy a handgun in accordance with law
but this is widely celebrated in the
media stacks that we support and respect
the Second Amendment we recognize and
appreciate the vast majority of gun
owners in the country are responsible
law-abiding citizens but we have to help
solve the problem that's in front of us
gun violence is an epidemic that's
taking the lives of too many people
including the brightest hope for the
future of America our kids well if you
believe that but if you believe that
then why not just stop selling all guns
if you believe that the the problem in
front of us is that all guns are the
threat and that the sale of legal
weapons to law-abiding citizens is the
real threat then maybe should stop
selling all guns in fact now stack
revealed that the shooter in this case
had purchased a shotgun at a at a store
at a dict store within the past four
months okay so
is anything that they're doing would
apparently I guess you know their new
rules that they won't sell to anybody
under 21 would have stopped him from
getting a gun at a dick store okay so he
waits until these 21 of them buys a gun
into Dick's store like if they actually
think the shotgun is the threat not the
person then they should be banning the
sale of all guns and they should just
stop selling guns to exporting goods and
I'm amazed sort of that the media have
fallen for this PR trap from Dick's but
this is what they have fallen for the
anchors over at CNN have made mockeries
of themselves as so as quote unquote
objective journalist I mean true
mockeries of themselves so Erin Burnett
right is is now she's supposed to be
objective journalist right she is she's
an anchor she's not a she's not an
opinion host she tweeted this out quote
politicians mail a purge to stand up to
the NRA but Dick's Sporting Goods USA's
largest sporting goods retailer will
stop selling assault-style weapons and
raise minimum age for all gun sales to
twenty one is that journalism or is that
advocacy obviously that's advocacy Chris
Cuomo had on the CEO and and the big
headline in the back said Dick's takes a
stand wow that's not advocacy at all
that's journalism dicks takes a stand
now the NRA is also taking a stand it's
just that Chris Cuomo doesn't like that
stance oh you'd never have on Dana lash
and then the background say NRA takes a
stand of course not because they're only
certain stands that CNN actually likes
and CNN has been doing this for weeks
now from the awful town-hall event to a
watching basic reporting about weapons
there was a CNN host yesterday who who
talked about a full semi-automatic which
doesn't even make any sense what the
hell is a full semi-automatic supposed
to mean now something out of mattress
means you pull the trigger once in a
bullet comes out okay but it's a full
semi-automatic and then there's a really
funny video of him trying to fire a
trying to fire a semi-automatic weapon
and the gun jumping in his hands because
he doesn't know how to fire a weapon
does not up locking into his shoulder
and my wife fires an AR better than he
fires an AR and then you know botching
basic facts about the weapons making
allowing these students to go on
national television and make
unquestioned about the evils of the
people with whom they are talking I make
an unquestioning about Marco Rubio being
an evil person and then we're supposed
to take CNN seriously okay here's a CNN
expert yesterday saying that women can't
carry guns because they wear dresses
like this is a real thing that they said
one of the things that people don't talk
about a lot of these school
Sandy Hook at an all-female faculty from
principal to teachers and for a woman
where are you gonna hide that gun during
the day you can't put it your desk
drawer somebody might steal it you can't
get to it
you're not gonna have it in a safe in
the principal's office you can't get to
it on your person if you wear a dress if
you were a skirt are you gonna have to
wear a jacket every day with a belt and
a holster the way a detective you know
on duty would do it's it's not a real
practical solution even for a variety of
reasons okay look how stupid this anchor
is where's the anchor I don't even know
who that anchor is she's sitting there
nodding through this whole thing
women wear pants I mean I hate to break
it to CNN but you know outside of hijab
land you know outside of like places
where women are forced to wear skirts
you know I'm forced to wear dresses all
over the world I'm not talking to all
Muslim communities are lots of Muslim
women who are pants outside of places
where women are forced to do that in a
free society like the United States lots
of women wear pants my wife wears pants
my mom wears pants all my sisters wear
pants okay I understand that that may be
mildly controversial in some Orthodox
Jewish circles but it is not rare in a
free country
lots of women wear pants and if you're
wearing a skirt there are lots of women
who wear skirts you know how to conceal
carrying oh they might have to wear a
jacket ooh
jackets cuz women never wear jackets and
what in the world this is being trotted
out as a normal talking point by the way
women also have purses many women carry
their guns in their purses unlike men
who actually have to conceal and carry
on their person women carrying around
their purses is the thing women carry
guns in their purses this is how they
defend themselves very often I mean how
sexist is that but that just goes right
by the wayside because the media are
attempting to portray all of this as
polish nez but now I do want to point
out something that I think is worth
pointing out because there are so many
people on the right who are willing to
jump to conclusions about the media
because the media are clearly biased in
these situations and they did jump to
conclusions and and we had a piece over
at the Daily wire while actually was
more of tweet from one of my writers of
a daily where we jump to a conclusion
about the notion that the town hall the
town hall was rigged so that certain
students were told that they couldn't
come because they wanted to ask certain
questions and so CNN banned them from
the proceedings it now turns out that
the Parkland one of the Parkland
shooting survivors fathers has admitted
to altering his evidence that CNN
scripted his Town Hall question I think
it's important to point
out in nature of intellectual honesty
there's a big confirmation bias that's
happening right now really strong
confirmation bias if you like what Jimmy
Kimmel is saying you pretend that he
knows what he's talking about and if you
think that CNN sucks then you're willing
to overlook false statements about CNN
I'm gonna go out of my way here to point
out that that was a false that was a
false report okay so it's not true that
CNN rigged the townhall by scripting
questions for the students it is true
obviously there is a selection bias in
play in terms of the audience when you
go to Broward County to a place where
it's pro-gun control anyway that voted
for Hillary Clinton you talked to a
bunch of students are pro-gun control
you're gonna end up with a gun control a
gun control show trial which is exactly
what happened there so that doesn't
justify the CNN show trial but that was
not pretty scripted the students were
not told what to say by the producers
over at CNN I just wanted to point that
out in the interest of in the interests
of honesty okay in other breaking news
there's been a lot of talk over the last
couple of days about Jared Kushner so
yesterday the White House chief of staff
John Kelly temporarily stripped all
White House staffers with interim
top-level security clearance of that
clearance instead downgraded everyone to
quote unquote secret security clearance
so this means that top secret material
can no longer be seen by Jared Jared had
interim top secret clearance so he could
see all this material and so jared has
basically been downgraded for at least
what they say is a short period of time
now he's 15 months in and the FBI has
still not fully cleared him one of the
reasons the FBI is not fully cleared him
is because he's involved in the Muller
investigation the Muller investigation
hasn't cleared anyone yet so the FBI has
not cleared anyone yet so anyone who's
even tangentially being investigated in
the Muller investigation anyone who's
been called in for questioning has not
yet received full security clearance
from the FBI so the longer that drags on
the longer the Muller investigation
suggesting Trump Russia collusion or
corruption drags on the longer it's
going to be before top security
clearance is regretted to people the
longer interim security clearance was in
play does this mean that there was a new
level of guilt found about Jared Kushner
no it doesn't mean anything of the sort
does it mean that there was a power play
by John Kelly here not really because
John Kelly did it to everyone including
Jared Kushner who had an interim
security clearance mainly because of the
blowback that he was receiving after Rob
Porter who had interim security
clearance was found to have not been
granted security clearance by the FBI
because of the allegations of
wife-beating so this was a response by
Kelly to the Rob Porter thing and
Kushner got caught up in the center
does that mean the jared is completely
clean I have no idea I don't know other
chair is completely clean the
investigation hasn't taken its full
course yet I assume that it will but the
media are working overtime to suggest
that the rejection of top secret
security clearance for Jared is an
indication of his guilt or his
corruption now listen I've said over and
over on the program isn't nepotism that
Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump in the
White House are having such large roles
of course that's not participate anat
recognize that nepotism exists
unfortunately on both sides of the aisle
I don't like it wherever I see it and it
was nepotistic when Chelsea Clinton was
was helping to be involved in the Bill
and Hillary foundation the Kennedys are
a team replete with nepotism the
nepotism exists in politics george w
bush is a product of nepotism there's
lots of nepotism in politics this is
just another example of nepotism in
politics but if we're now going to
suggest that anyone who is once rejected
for FBI top-secret security clearance
not just put on interim holds Gerardus
but rejected for top-secret security
clearance is out-of-bounds and corrupt
then we ought to start with someone who
actually was rejected by the FBI for
top-secret security clearance that of
course would be Obama White House deputy
national security adviser Ben Rhodes now
it's amazing is back in January and not
very long ago in January 2017
okay the Washington free beacon reported
that Ben Rhodes was openly rejected by
the FBI for his clearance and then he
was cleared by the Obama administration
under vague circumstances they just went
around the FBI and Obama granted him
clearance nobody said boo nobody cared
Ben Rhodes is one of the architects of
the awful horrible terrible immoral Iran
ziyal and nobody said a word about any
of this again the media didn't seem to
care very much about that but cushion
our end of the world that obviously
means he's corrupted obvious means he's
terrible that seems ridiculous to me
also worth noting that when it comes to
the that when it comes to this other
report that there are four different
countries that were looking to
manipulate Jared Mexico Israel China and
the UAE I am sure that they were looking
for ways to manipulate members of the
Obama administration as well the
question isn't do foreign governments
try to manipulate American American
government members the question is are
they successful in doing so or do they
actually have real leverage we don't
know the answer to that yet so the media
jumping to conclusion about Kushner and
suggesting that this just demonstrates
that there's infighting in the White
House there's chaos and the end of the
if you don't buy any of that wait for
more evidence as always wait for
evidence don't jump to the conclusion
that the media would like for you to
jump to okay so before I go any further
you're gonna have to go over to Daly
wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a month
you can have subscription to Daly wire
that means you get the rest of this show
live the rest of the Enric Levin show
live the rest of the Michael Noel's show
live it means that you also get to be
part of our mailbag which we are having
on Fridays if you want all of those
things plus the magical leftist Cheers
hot or cold tumblr which I wouldn't even
bring with me on this on this gentleman
because it's just too valuable then get
an annual subscription that's just $99 a
year please go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe but please
leave us a review it always helps us we
really appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all right so just to show you how biased
the media have been on the Jared and
Ivanka matter let me show you a couple
clips from the media one of these
particularly is really really really
funny so Rachel Maddow
you know she over on MSNBC she says that
the Trump administration is a cautionary
tale about nepotism so here here's what
Rachel Maddow had to say in the future
the textbook explanation the textbook
case studies about nepotism about a
friends-and-family approach to
governance right in the future when
there are after-school specials about
the uzbek Astana's ation of the american
government and what's wrong with that
and why it doesn't work and what could
possibly go wrong those stories will all
be crystal clear no ambiguity because of
what we're living through now and
thereby maybe future generations will
figure out how to avoid this particular
kind of mess we must we must avoid
nepotism at all costs also Hillary
Clinton was just the best just amazing
she deserved a Senate seat because she
once had sex with Bill just a very very
important that we fighting up it's ism
on every level also Joe Kennedy the
third will be giving the response to the
State of the Union address but that was
not even the funny one okay here I want
to show you this one clip cuz it is so
freaking funny okay so Mika Brzezinski
over on MSNBC of Morning Joe thin here
she is talking about Ivanka and Jared
and their a joke and they been given
fake jobs and it's all despotism here's
a chance to say he came in there to
fight for women and she can't handle a
question like that the whole thing
clearly is a joke an utter joke just
like milania's role on cyber you know
bullying which i think is an insult to
women completely and expected a john
kelly to be forced to put out a nice
statement about Ivanka and how effective
she is well I mean Melania faulting two
women these women have been given fake
jobs they've been given fake chats it's
all nepotism they've been giving fake
things to do Ivanka and Melania okay I
would like to point out the makeup
Brzezinski is the daughter of big Mia
Brzezinski who's the national security
adviser under Jimmy Carter so if we're
gonna talk about nepotism and people who
have made it based on their names Mika
Brzezinski may have something to say
about that but again the hypocrisy is of
no consequence to people who spend all
day trafficking
in it okay so meanwhile there's a lot of
talk about deca so deca is about to come
up for renewal or killing on March 5th
so next week we're gonna get a lot of
headlines in media about how the end of
the world is nigh about how dreamers are
going to be deported on mass about how
the now we're the pedal hits the metal
and we'd better make some room for these
dreamers or Trump is just an evil racist
bigoted pig before you read it in those
headlines I would like to point out that
Trump's proposal on Jackyl was
significantly more generous than Barack
Obama's proposal and daca daca only
legalized 700,000 illegal immigrants
president Trump's proposal would have
legalized 1.8 million illegal immigrants
and let another 4 million 4 million
legal immigrants come in through chain
migration over the next 15 years as the
Center for Immigration Studies proposes
in return all he wanted was 25 billion
dollars to build that Trump wall and
some additional funding for border
security as well as some curbs on chain
migration but he did not get those the
Democrats didn't give them to him and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is exactly right
when she said the Trump did go above and
beyond on daca he did a lot more than
Obama ever did he's encouraging that's
why he laid out exactly what he expected
to see in a proposal that would not only
help solve the daca problem but also
provide border security the president
went above and beyond what previous
administrations have done and offered on
that program it's really sad that
Democrats are not willing to come to the
table get something done and actually
fix problems and do their job and of
course that is 100% true let's hear
Huckabee Sanders is saying there but
Democrats are not coming to the table
and they're not coming to the table for
one very specific reason and that is
they think that Republicans lose this
issue no matter what they feel like
either Trump reinstates daca illegally
and overthrow his own promise gets
blowback from his base or he leaves daca
or he or he leaves daca dead and he
starts deporting people that's probably
not what's gonna happen here by the way
because Lindsey Graham who is really
soft on immigration he gives some
political analysis here that is not
completely wrong he says that if daca
ends and if all these daca recipients
are deported that it's gonna be bad
politically for Republicans this is
probably correct even if you disagree
with him on the policy of it we did
nothing and just
indeed dhaka and did nothing else and a
lot of these young people start getting
deported than that that would destroy
the party so I don't think that's even a
viable option now Trump knows that which
is why the chance is that he is going to
start deporting millions of people are
really really low right it's the reason
why Trump is not going to do this okay
the daca is is not gonna be reinstated
and all likelihood but Trump is just not
gonna deport these folks and that means
they won't be able to get work permits
it means that theoretically they could
be subject to future deportation but we
all know that it's only a matter of time
until somebody gives them amnesty it'll
probably be Trump it could be somebody
after Trump these folks will be given
amnesty because no one has the political
stones to actually say that people who
are here illegally and work came and his
children should be deported now so I
think they should actually be deported I
think that we should analyze on a
one-to-one basis whether people ought to
be in the country and if we have the
ability as a country to decide who ought
to be here and who ought not be here
then we should determine which of these
dreamers are actually people who are of
benefit to the United States and which
ones are not you don't have a right to
be here just because you were brought
here through no fault of your own if
somebody illegally sneaked you into
Disneyland Disneyland would not have to
then give you a day pass that's not the
way that this works does anyone have to
determine whether it's in their interest
for you to stay well the United States
it's the same sort of deal that said I
think this all ends with basically
nothing happening but it doesn't matter
that Trump has offered the most the most
generous immigration package that I've
seen in ten years really since in 12
years since since the bush immigration
package in 2006 it's it's not enough for
Democrats and Trump his white
supremacist so it does not matter the
president from just offered to amnesty
two million people right off the bat
luis Gutierrez came out he says that
Trump is an ethnocentric pro-european
pro white agenda the GOP is a racist
party this is the way the Democrats are
gonna campaign underneath the dreamers
and then crow his position on
immigration in an ethnocentric
pro-european Pro white agenda that will
hurt America but it must start with my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle saying yes we want to solve the
problem and we want to rise above the
racism emanating from the White House
okay so this is the this is the tack
Democrats are going to take good luck
with this okay there
attempt to paint Trump as a deep racist
in the last campaign it failed if they
continue to push this line that Trump is
a deep racist it's not going to work
not because Trump hasn't said things
that are racist before I think he
probably has and in fact I know he has
but because people do not proceed from
as a racist they perceive him as like
grandpa from 1960 who says some stuff
that you wouldn't want said outside your
kitchen that's it that's basically how
people perceive Trump is it right to
perceive him that way probably not is
that the way people do perceive him yes
is his policy racist and when we get
down to the policy is it racist of
course not the policy prescriptions that
he's put forward are not racist
they may not be things you agree with
but it's very difficult to label them
racist it doesn't matter Democrats are
going to continue to go radical on this
joy joy behar says Republicans have a
penchant for Nazis okay which comes as a
shock to me since I've been a lifelong
Republican and I freaking hate Nazis
since they come after me all the time
and they are evil but here's joy behar
making that case on the view this woman
from France named marine lepen whose
father was a Holocaust denier and a
total fascist and a Nazi and marine
lepen the daughter thinks her father was
very good and right and everything else
and they invited her there's this like
penchant for Nazis now you know with
charlottesville and the Neos and they're
good guys on both sides and now marine
lepen
it's like a lot of the people in the
Republican Party that I remember Bill
Buckley who fought in World War two you
know Bill Kristol those people who are
so anti-nazi are appalled by what's
going on right now in within this party
so I don't think that Marianne lepen
should been invited to CPAC I said so
publicly that said if we're going to
talk about you know branding the entire
Republican Party not see because
Marianne lepen showed up at CPAC invited
then we're gonna also have to talk about
Louis Farrakhan being invited to all the
top halls of power and the Deputy Chair
of the DCC of the DNC spending time with
Louis Farrakhan and the entire
Congressional Black Caucus spending time
with Louis Farrakhan Lewis Farrakhan is
every bit the Nazi the Marion lepen is
and much more openly so again there are
bad apples and this is not a what about
ism think Marion Levin should not have
been invited to CPAC Republicans should
not have been embracing Marion lepen
Republicans should not have embraced the
alt-right I was very loud and proud
about this for years but to suggest that
the Republicans are the sole repository
of races of an anti 7
is just inaccurate okay both parties
have some problems with this and both
parties need to do something bad but
only one party has policies that reflect
anti-semitism that party is not the
party of Donald Trump unfortunately
right now unfortunately there are a lot
of folks in the Democratic Party whose
policy prescriptions particularly with
regard to Israel are much more aligned
with Richard Spencer and with and with
Lewis Farrakhan than they are with some
of the names that Joy Behar just stated
okay time for a quick thing I like and
then a quick thing that I hate so things
that I like today I just started at the
recommendation of my sister watching the
Frankenstein Chronicles with one of my
favorite actors Sean Bean Sean Bean is
wonderful and I've only watched the
first episode and a half it is really
creepy okay this is not for kids and
it's not for the faint of heart but
basically the premise is that he is a
cop in early in in early 19th century
Britain I believe this is the time
period this is taking place on and like
Dickens is London basically and he is
checking out a murder when he comes
across a body that's been stitched
together of a ver a variety of different
parties of a variety of different bodies
here's a little bit of a preview
[Music]
this thing is a confident okay so as you
can see it's a period piece I'm a sucker
for period pieces I like them it's it's
it's really creepy it's well acted it's
well written so far I check it out on
Netflix if this is the sort of thing
that appeals to you okay a quick thing
that I hate okay so today's thing I
think comes courtesy of Chuck Schumer
Chuck Schumer apparently does not have
know how either Netflix or sex sex work
I don't I really mean that here here's
what Chuck Schumer tweeted he was
treating my net neutrality the entire
Democratic Party decided they were gonna
tweet about net neutrality yesterday
they don't know anything about net
neutrality and it's pretty obvious
literally it's Oh Chuck Schumer tweeted
without net neutrality when a couple is
streaming their favorite Netflix show
but it keeps lagging and killing the
mood who will be to blame no one uses
Netflix for foreplay dude that's weird
in fact Netflix they're they're actually
a fair number of studies that suggest
that streaming television has actually
lowered the number of times people have
sex in a given month because too many
people are watching Netflix and then
it's too late and they're tired they go
to bed instead of having sex with one
another
I love the Chuck Schumer thinks that
streaming is what makes sex happen right
this is not true streaming may make
other things happen through pornography
but streaming does not make sex happen
the people who are watching Netflix are
the ones least likely to be having sex
if you're busy watching the Frankenstein
Chronicles you're not using that as
foreplay on Netflix but the Democrats
were tweeting about this incessantly
yesterday yeah they were tweeting out
that if net net neutrality happens then
the internet will be brought to you one
word at a time I don't know what the
hell that means
and then they double spaced it to annoy
everybody if you're gonna make arguments
people on in the Democratic Party gonna
have to do better you're gonna have to
have some people who are younger to make
these arguments on net neutrality who
know what the internet is
and what a computer is and what
bandwidth is and what streaming looks
like who have ever watched a show on
Netflix how about some people who don't
actually get cable right and most of
people my age at this point are not
getting cable they're getting Netflix or
Amazon or Hulu or something I wonder how
many members of the Democratic Party
have cut the cable yet my guess is very
few the same is true in the Republican
Party by the way all of our political
parties are out of touch with modern
technology and it definitely shows okay
so tonight I will be speaking in Omaha
and as
we'll be making a full defense of the
Second Amendment and we'll talk about
the history of it I will talk about the
legality of it I will talk about which
guns are protected what types of folks
are protected I will talk about all of
those things I look forward to seeing
you there and we'll be back here
tomorrow back from our haunts in Los
Angeles I will see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Applause]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis lover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing